they sent me their whole pitch tag and
stuff and they really are trying to get
regular creators on that app maybe it'll
take I'm sexy the chances that you're
going to do only fans
[Music]
so I'm glad we have Kristen here because
Christian really has taken off on Tick
Tock during her duration of her lifetime
my short 13 years
so uh
in terms of using like Tick Tock or
Instagram which one do you prefer using
yeah
like which one do you think is more
beneficial in terms of like growing
socially like oh like numbers yeah like
businesses
okay
it's changing a little bit oh to what
um I feel like the algorithm when I got
on it like if I was consistent and
posted like the numbers were crazy now
there's like a little bit of over
saturation tick tock's now becoming
um they're trying to be an SEO like
search engine type thing so they're
pushing more videos that like people
would type into Google best restaurants
in La those types of videos so it's a
little bit different for creators right
now I think and then you have Instagram
on the other hand trying to copy
everything tick tock's doing so they're
starting to push reals so I feel like
it's easy to grow on that but cool yeah
I'm glad you brought that up because
there's a leaked uh document that uh was
sent internally on meta that was
reporting the results of Instagram
pushing reels and Facebook pushing
shorts and uh it turns out it was pretty
much a failure
what's a failure real says what do you
mean a failure in the sense that as much
as they were trying to be like Tick Tock
the engagement that they were able to
overall all attract in terms of like
more people seeing things more people
using it no matter what they did Tick
Tock is easily 10x whatever Instagram
and Facebook get yeah it's the user base
also like I'm not going to Instagram to
scroll through reels if I go to tick
tock for that you know I feel like
Instagram had its base and was strong
with that and what Instagram was and
when you're trying to bite someone
else's idea I feel like it's just not as
successful I also think Instagram's
layout like where reels are and stuff
like it's so weird I don't know not good
just stick to pictures huh
for Instagram well uh yeah I don't know
or like level up in your own way don't
just like try to take what another
platform is doing successfully and try
to add it to your own I think they just
Instagram is a little bit too much right
now I think every platform right now is
just trying to like like mooch off The
Tick Tock game because like YouTube has
YouTube shorts now yeah YouTube's doing
it even even Facebook has their like
weird like Facebook and like Instagram
everyone's doing like Tick Tock even
Reddit like you scroll through it it's
like formatted like Tick Tock it's got
the comments on the side it's like
they're all trying to do the same
formula try to emulate Tick Tock but
nobody can do it like Tick Tock yeah so
that's exactly what this shows is that
as much as everyone tried it they didn't
get to what they wanted to get and uh
Instagram and supply for uh Tick Tock is
by far literally the numbers are 10
times wow and that's just people seeing
it people using it yeah maybe they drove
more people on Instagram to watch reels
because they had no choice because it's
just can't escape it yeah it's there
yeah but in terms of voluntary
engagement where I'm here because I want
to be Tick Tock is 100 that
and uh yeah yeah it didn't work out did
Tick Tock eight point copy something
that someone else did
um like any of the internet the only
thing I can think of is you know there's
that new platform be real yeah have you
guys heard of that yeah in real time
yeah I think that's a cool idea but I
saw a copy from that that Tick Tock did
Tick Tock made a filter oh where it's
like the because on be real there's the
front camera and back camera on one
photo Tick Tock made a filter filter
like that that you can use I feel like
everyone's just like using it on Tick
Tock as much I mean not as not really
huh to be fair though like filters are
something that people can make as well
you can like anybody can make any kind
of filter right so
is it like a like a built-in feature
like their stories because they they
have Tick-Tock stories too now dude yeah
Tick Tock more than anything uh yeah
like I'm scrolling on there like I used
to be on YouTube all the time but like
nowadays I usually if I'm trying to kill
time I'm just on Tick Tock that's it's
really short and you can be on there for
10 minutes and then leave yeah that's
what killed a lot of creators on YouTube
though not killed but like depleted oh
yeah like YouTube lost a lot of uh
viewers to tick tock and I'm sorry so
sorry that's just the game of the
internet like we've seen things change
like quick right yeah so I feel like now
the way people are consuming YouTube is
like podcasts long content or really
well polished content yeah like the way
that they watch Netflix but then you
know more independent yeah I agree and
then with Tick Tock it's like what all
the other YouTube channels were like if
you're like whatevers or I don't know
like they
or maybe Vlogs even like a lot of [ __ ]
can't be condemned condensed yeah a lot
of people now because I feel like this
is happening for a lot of YouTube
vloggers is uh people are vlogging on
Tick Tock now or they're just making
like a little Montage of their day and
just the very personal vlogging style
yeah and a lot of people are watching
that and it's quick and it's easier than
YouTube so I think that's making
vlogging struggle a little bit on
YouTube because people are going to tick
tock for that too damn okay because
there was a time when Vlog channels were
like crushing it on YouTube and then
like
all across the board like for me and my
friends and I don't know anyone that's
still crushing it and vlogging the way
that it was like five years oh no way
yeah that's that's pretty rough so when
you started Tick Tock would you say that
like you blew up pretty quickly yeah it
took me about I posted for two months
consistently like posted every single
day it happened because I had a friend
who was sleeping on my couch and
uh he had just moved to LA I helped him
out I'm like stay on my couch and he
started doing Tick Tock and like posting
a lot he's a beat boxer and he blew up
on Tick Tock just beatboxing in in like
six months he gained 50 million
followers oh my God became a
multi-millionaire I saw and he still
slept on your couch no
no no no he because it was it that same
day he was still there these are my
Louis Vuitton sheets on the couch I'll
be boxing just 50 million followers from
just beatboxing granted he is really
talented but like he was so consistent
with it and I saw that change his life
and covet happened and I was like okay I
need to make money I was about an
expensive apartment with that model guy
and uh yeah I was like I need to do
something so I started posting on Tick
Tock I was consistent for about two
months and like wasn't getting any
traction and just one day a video blew
up and it was just like was it this one
the freaking yeah the flip one yeah so
easy anyway that's something that she
could have done any day for years yeah I
know I know like Tick Tock is always
like the dumbest [ __ ] you wouldn't
expect to blow up that blows up like if
you put effort into a wow
wow
I mean it's [ __ ] as [ __ ] you would
never think yeah the most uncreated
thing you've ever seen is blown out
bottom of the barrel yeah you know like
when you like put effort into your
videos right I put enough for it yeah
and then it's like the ones that you put
like so much time into it's like oh I
didn't do as well but then like you
forget what you're saying yeah I just
like I just gotta piss me out today boom
that's how we felt about YouTube That's
The Magic of everything that's a lot
just don't put that into it it's
consistency for sure one of my fitness
friends that's pretty big on Tick Tock
he was telling me he used to post uh 20
times a day and just the ones that did
good he kept the ones that don't do good
he deletes it's consistency it really is
constantly just putting like 20 videos
up a day I wonder what fine feels like
because they're like that's what we
could have is there still someone on
there just trying to [ __ ] posting
every day he's like come on man won't
you so what how fast did you go from uh
how fast did you get to take to get to a
million oh probably like
like I said I was posting for two months
then it hit and then probably a month
after that I got like most of my
following like in a month and a half
maybe and this was all during Clovis
stagnant now because like I said I got
into I kind of took a break from it same
thing how you guys fell off how this is
gonna get no views but damn okay
I'm not sure thank you thank you nobody
stop posting for a while and I kind of
jacked my stuff
she said that Stone Face yeah she's a
good delivery Honestly YouTube is like
the Vegas of social media
yeah this is where this is where people
come for the last leg of their career
like that you see you see Backstreet
Boys and then their events were the
Britney Spears
yeah you see Britney Spears at the
Mirage okay see everyone and then
finally the other on YouTube I guess
they're just gonna be here now
yeah the superstars are on Tick Tock
yeah and then maybe twitch
oh yeah we switched to they're dying
yeah that's another place to die it's
just banned they're going gambling [ __ ]
oh yeah I heard about it people can't
gamble anymore and I feel like that's
such an entertaining thing how would you
watch people gamble yeah they won't
allow gambling on there anymore wait do
they count like csgo knife skin stuff
like that is that gambling no that's
Loot Crate stuff I think that doesn't
count as gambling right Loot Crate does
not count yeah
I know it probably is next to go but I
feel like the best social media right
now is only Vans well twitch it probably
is like like the gamer chicks the gamer
chicks that do twitch and only fans are
probably like doing eight figures a year
oh yeah yeah easily yeah but that's
where only fans are right now is because
they re like they sent me their whole
pitch deck and stuff and they really are
trying to get regular creators on that
app maybe it'll take I'm sexy the
chances that you're gonna do only fans
as a non-nude Creator honestly pretty
high I want to have like a I don't know
I want to see what's up with it see if
it's worth it can you tell them you have
a friend that's down to do nude [ __ ]
and just CC me on the email where's the
JK only fan you can just do this but
nude
as a person of Youth what do you think
what do you think a JK only fans should
have
everything you serious like what does
that mean toes the toes the good Lord
you think people want that shirt oh dude
you'd be surprised people on the
internet go feral for feet so maybe
instead of the cameras pointing from
here it should be what's under the desk
oh yeah and the only one above it no no
face content it's just our feet going
like
[Music]